"At the close of the age of fire,
all lands meet at the end of the Earth.
Great Kingdoms and anemic
townships will be one and the same.
A great tide of human enterprise - all for naught.
That's why I'm so taken by this grand sight
This must be what it's like to be a god"
Welcome, everyone, to the Ringed City.
So I can show you ten minutes
of this first level and then I can show you about five minutes of the boss.
I got this Splitleaf Greatsword from the hag just before and it's really good.
Don't judge me. She saw me die. It was embarrassing, she had to go;
but as she died she said something about hoping to see an angel
And, it looks like she just missed it. Damn.
Actually, I'm pretty sure it's her death that caused this angel to spawn
because I've never seen it here before her death
but we'll talk about the angels more later
The first weapon we have in our sights is the Aquamarine Dagger.
Which is just beyond this Harald Legion knight
The Harald Legion, according to their gear, once came here seeking the Dark Soul.
However, they eventually sank into the dark; their weapons corroding and their bodies bloating
And we don't know yet: maybe they did find the Dark Soul in some capacity
For their head appears to be this swirling mass of humanity
Which if you jump attack it can save you a difficult fight
Above is the lightsaber - I mean Aquamarine Dagger, and it has a weapon art
That's like Freida's scythe where it extends the blade and your move set at the cost of some movement speed and focus
and your move set at the cost of some movement speed and focus
The dagger reads "It is fitted with aquamarine crystals
and engraved with a prayer in the old tongue to ward off incidents."
Perhaps it is a parting gift given to one sent out on great travels
It's quite effective against these Murkmen
and the Murkmen are like human corpses that are corroded by the dark
Some, as you'll see here, are possessed by Souldregs
which, and I quote, "have a grave likeness to the human form."
Apparently you can destroy these Souldregs as they fly towards you-look at this
I only figured this out because I rolled with the Thorns armor on, which does damage when you roll, and
That probably would have been really useful information in this scenario:
But back to the dagger. I think this will be a top-tier weapon in terms of Fashion and in terms of damage
It's pretty great against humanoid enemies because it can stun lock them,
but as you'll see during the boss fight later
Activating the weapon art can be a bit of a liability
Next, the angel.
If you have a keen eye, then you would have noticed this pillar of light in the distance
It illuminates at the same time the angel appeared so I ran down there to check it out and then:
This pillar breaks through a cathedral wall and reveals the path to Lapp, the amnesiac Hollow.
"Oh, look at you. You've got your head screwed on correct. Fantastic
To miss a kindred spirit on this gods-forsaken crag. call me Lapp
I-I can't remember my real name, so
let's just go with that. I have a feeling we're going to make a fabulous team."
He just said we'd make a fabulous team. Where's the team work?
I feel like it's not in this guy's character to help me.
Let's try again
"Oh, you'll see - you'll see!"
"Ohh,
In all honesty there's something. I should tell you... I'm... a Hollow
Yes, I try to play it off
But I haven't a clue about my past. Who I was, or what I lived for.
Not even my own blessed name.
That's why I've come here searching. For the Purging Monument
Said to be in the Ringed City where the pygmies, who found the Dark Soul at the dawn of fire, reside.
All I can say is...
Those little stones aren't doing much to help me remember anymore..."
The little stones he's talking about are obviously Purging Stones,
which are commonly used in Londor to cure Hollowing and to stave off the Undead Curse
And for someone who is as immortal as Lapp
Whose identity we were pretty sure of in the last video if you want to spoil it.
Apparently for him even these stones stop being effective after a while
Back down below Lapp is our original target
Which was this thing which I've started calling the "Londor Grower"
It's this fleshy parasite that appears to be attached over the shell of a dead Pilgrim and
I always assumed that the shells were like those shells that you saw on the blue robed clerics
which state that the shells keep out the puss of man.
Which is that black muck that had infested the rest of Lothric.
So the fact that this avatar, this parasite, appears over the shell of the Pilgrim
leads me to believe that whatever this creature is
its what the pilgrim wanted to become.
after all it's kind of like a caterpillar becoming butterfly after the Cocoon phase and
after all the pilgrims of Londor,
as we learn from Yoel, were destined to die and craved death
So perhaps this rebirth into an angel is their goal and
I guess for Hollows it is a more powerful form
and this certainly is a step forward - at least in terms of evolution.
But what is their goal now? That's what we've yet to discover.
A bunch more pilgrims can be found in this arena
where you fight one more Harald Knight
and beyond this a drop down into the next zone that I'm not allowed to show you.
But I am allowed to show you this:
"Far below,
there's a deep dark hole
carved out of a tree
from time to time
voices brim from the Depths of the Cavity even now
Mutterings of a merry Demon that Prince Lorian spoke of I'm sure
Horrible sounds of an afflicted thing
yet cursing men."
The Demon Prince.
This fight has changed.
Where in a previous patch you were only beset by one Demon at the start
Now there are two at the start, though I'd argue that they do a bit less damage now from what I remember
The boss really shouldn't be called the Demon from Below
It should be called camera because that's what you're really fighting.
Though it's not a bad fight. It's quite good.
It just gets a little too chaotic at times in my opinion.
So the main mechanic when there's two of them is this
When a demon is red that means it's powered up
And it means that it will tend towards using fire-imbued melee attacks
Eventually though it will lose that flame with a slam attack and then will resort to
poison, toxic and corrosion until it powers up again and
This poison form is where most of your damage should come in
and it's also where the Demon Prince will come out
The Demon Prince, after his defeat to Lorian,
Retreated beneath the Earth
and lost the memory of the flame that burned within him, marking the end of Demon-kind.
The weapons from his soul of the Last Flames kindled by the Prince and
with the death of the Old Demon King in the overworld
surely these mark the end of Chaos and it's Demons.
One fact remains the same here though:
Depending on which one you kill first the move set of the Demon Prince will change
so if you kill the one on the right, the Demon in Pain, first
You'll face a version of the Demon Prince with laser attacks
and this version is far easier in my opinion because he's at a-
(...)
Yeah...
just don't get hit.
And if you kill the one on the left first, the Demon from Below
Then it will lead to a Demon Prince fight with true Chaos flame attacks
he summons these orbs that bombard you from a distance and
This meteor storm that I could never effectively dodge.
It killed me so hard that it fucking broke my editing software
Ultimately though, this boss is undone by a high stability, high fire resistant shield
You don't even need to dodge really just use the Black Knight shield.
So the last thing I want to leave you on is this:
I think it's a good statement to go into the DLC with
from a lore point of view anyway,
so the Harald knights came down here seeking the Dark Soul and they failed.
A wanderer apparently on "great travels" was given the Aquamarine Dagger
and left it behind and I think that maybe Prince Lothric (Lorian) might has been here, too
Since he defeated the Demon Prince before it burrowed deep beneath the ground
nursing it's wounds. And of course Gail is summonable for this fight
and we know why he's down here.
All of these people likely where here looking for the dark soul
and the question becomes:
Why were they seeking the Dark Soul?
What powers does it have and
can it really create a new world as Gail and Arya hope for?
One more week and we'll know.
Thank you for watching.
Also, if you want to learn everything we currently know about the Ringed city
albeit without footage to back it up
You can watch this video,
and I believe there's a new trailer dropping soon
so go and check that out.
Thank you for watching.